[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander rose and the
executive director here at the long now
foundation and I'm gonna be hosting
editing the QA for this evening I think
it's both lucky on my part because
Marsha was suggesting to both mine and
board member Paul Sappho's I think we
both had the experience of reading this
book and kind of dog-earing page after
page after page and realizing how
important it was to bring her to this
audience kind of her insights in this
book really are some of the very same
things that instigated long now at the
beginning as many of you know we start
these talks with a what's called a long
short a short film about long term
thinking and I think as in a first we
have a long short that was created by
fin Marcia's son with her for this talk
so enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as I mentioned yeah this is one of
those books he as I was reading it I
realized more and more how it was so in
line with long now's very origins and
that literally this idea of time fulness
that Martha writes about is very
literally the concept of lengthening our
now and and and I think one of my
favorite things about talking with
astronomers and geologists is they're
the only people who make our ten
thousand year timeframe seem positively
tiny and quaint and but I think she does
it in a way that is a very human centric
and so I'm very excited to hear from
Marcia be honored this evening thank you
[Music]
Thank You Xander and Danielle and Andrew
and all the others who have made my my
visit here so it's so wonderful well I'm
not sure how common an experience it is
for Californians but for children who
grew up in a wintry climate few events
in life will ever deliver the same pure
joy as a snow day time is temporarily
repealed the oppressive schedules of the
adult world magically suspended in a
concession to the greater authority of
nature
I recall one particular snow day when I
was growing up in rural Wisconsin in the
1970s there'd been a ferocious blizzard
in the night with heavy snow and high
winds that by morning had brought bitter
cold but I couldn't resist going out to
survey the transformed world trees
creaked and groaned as they do when it
is especially cold I spotted a dab of
red on a branch and saw that it was a
cardinal I started walking toward it in
in the heavy snow and was surprised when
it didn't move I got closer still and
then realized with both revulsion and
fascination that it was frozen on the
branch it was this time itself had been
frozen and I was able to witness
something that was normally a blur of
motion back in the house later the same
day I remember heaving our unwieldy
world atlas down off the shelf where I
remember it's at right next to the Whole
Earth Catalog and paging through it I
came to a map of time zones around the
world with the globe divided mostly into
longitudinal stripes of alternating
color but there were several places
Antarctica Outer Mongolia and one I'd
never heard of Svalbard high in the
Arctic that were colored gray the legend
said these places had no official time I
was captivated by the idea of enclaves
that had somehow resisted being shackled
by measures of time no minutes or hours
wholly exempt from the tyranny of a
schedule was time they're frozen like
the Cardinal on a branch or simply
flowing unmetered and unfettered
according to a Wilder natural rhythm my
next encounter was fall Bart happened a
few years later at an exhibit of
Scandinavian photography at the
Minneapolis Institute of Art most of the
pieces were predictably moody modern
Nordic were
but my attention was caught by several
haunting images of the ill-fated Eagle
expedition an 1897 attempt by three
Swedes to fly over the North Pole in a
hot-air balloon
within days of its launch the balloon
went off course and crashed on the sea
ice off one of the most bleak and remote
islands in this part archipelago no one
knew however what had happened to the
expedition until more than thirty years
later when the wreckage was discovered
and filmed that was still in the cameras
at the site was developed silently
documenting the disaster and the slow
demise of the Explorers this only
reaffirmed my conviction that this place
Svalbard was somehow and timeless
outside time as it happened I would end
up doing my PhD research in Svalbard and
later spent additional summer field
seasons there as a geologist working
with the Norwegian polar Institute I
quickly learned that the no official
time designation was nothing as romantic
as I had imagined but instead the result
of a long-running political spat between
the Norwegians and Russians about
whether to use Oslo or Moscow time there
and I began to understand that the place
was not timeless but intact in fact time
full when I first arrived there in the
1980s it still felt like the Pleistocene
the Ice Age the place was still firmly
in the grip of ice artefacts from the
last few centuries of human activity
were strewn sparsely across the vast
landscape as if in a poorly curated
museum display there were whale bones
scattered on the tundra remnants from
17th century dutch blubber rendering
there were 18th century russian graves
from the time of catherine the great
when exile to Svalbard was a slow death
penalty
there were Hut's built of driftwood by
19th century miners and hunters with old
boots in the corner and rusty tin cans
still on the shelves and there was the
sinister wreckage of a Luftwaffe plane
untouched since the 1940s of profane and
malign presence in that beautifully
austere landscape somehow all these
pastimes signified by these objects
seemed equally close all still palpably
present my field research focused on
understanding the tectonic evolution of
the northernmost part of the Appalachian
Caledonian mountain belt and immersed in
this war
in a place so remote from modern life I
began to feel that this 400 million year
old event and the still older rocks
recording it were more proximal in time
than the 20th century world in places
like Svalbard with comparatively little
human clutter it's easy to sense the
presence of the past but everywhere the
natural world is bursting with
backstories the world is made of or more
precisely by time this is what I mean by
time fulness an awareness of the rich
natural history that envelops us a sense
that we to live in geologic time and are
part of a continuum from the planets
past into its future time fulness is a
deliberate counterpoint to timelessness
an unattainable sterile and I will argue
even dangerous idea but we live in a
time illiterate society as I don't need
to tell this audience we would be
shocked if we an educated adult had no
idea where the continents were on that
global map but don't seem bothered by
the fact that few average people have a
good sense of the geography of the
planet's past even though we will spend
our entire lives here we behave like bad
tourists on earth enjoying its amenities
and ransacking its bounty without ever
having noticed that it has its own
ancient language and customs many of the
environmental problems we face of arisen
because we collectively lack a sense for
the duration of chapters in Earth's
history the rates of geologic processes
like groundwater flow or the intrinsic
timescales of natural phenomena like
climate change I suspect that you
Californians with the San Andreas and
related faults just beneath your feet
might be more in tune with the planet's
rhythms than the average earthling but
in our culture time denial or what we
might call chrono phobia is rampant and
comes in many varieties arising from
different sources the most obvious and
vocal is of course young Earth
Creationism
but it's worth noticing that noting that
200 years ago geology and theology were
really not at odds and in fact the
scientific discovery of deep time to use
John McPhee's evocative phrase was
actually motivated by religious belief
the beginning of modern geology as a
discipline is usually traced to ask
shots Minh james hutton who was a
physician gentleman farmer naturalist
and polymath on the fringes of the
Edinburgh enlightenment he often drank
and dined with the likes of the
philosopher David Hume the inventor
James Watt economist Adam Smith and
apparently Ben Franklin even visited him
once as a landowner Hutton was concerned
for economic reasons at the large amount
of soil he could see was being washed
away to the sea every year as a
religious person a dais like many
Enlightenment thinkers he was also
troubled spiritually by the idea that
God would simply allow the earth to be
worn steadily away that sometime in the
future all of the continents would be
eroded to sea-level and that the earth
would be uninhabitable by humans his
writing suggested he was actively
looking for evidence of some
compensatory process of rejuvenation and
he found it late in his life at this
rocky promontory off the coast of
Scotland siccar point the east coast so
what we see are two sequences of rocks
an underlying sequence in which the the
beds are nearly vertical and then a
second sequence of rocks partly
overlapping that vertical sequence that
are almost horizontal but in fact
slightly tilted and here's an
illustration from my book and I should
mention that the illustrations in the
book are done by a former student of
mine who impressed me with her fossil
sketches in an intro geology class so
here's a rendition that's a little
simpler to understand these two
sequences of rock Hutton back in 1788
made the the great intuitive
interpretation that the older sequence
of rocks tilted on end represented the
vestiges of an ancient mountain belt and
the contact between these two sequences
of rocks represented the time it would
take to erode a mountain belt back to
sea-level and then have a succeeding
sequence of rocks deposited on top and
so he recognized that surely the 6000 or
so years it was allotted by a literal
reading of the Bible was certainly not
enough time to the road a mountain belt
to the sea Hutton made an even greater
inductively
and surmised that the rocks at siccar
point recorded just one of countless
cycles of uplift erosion over the
history of the earth
his 1788 treatise theory of the earth
published the year before he died
famously ends with a sentence the result
therefore of our present end query is
that we find no vestige of a beginning
no prospect of an end so Hutton gave us
great deep time but he wasn't
particularly interested in any granular
details of what precisely happened
during those vast Econ eons Hutus
beautiful idea of an earth that was
infinitely old and continuously
regenerating captured the public
imagination in the way that space
exploration
does in our time this is a depiction of
Hutton's unconformity from 1802 was
actually three years after he died that
was widely circulated in Britain and the
US and ignited public interest in the
emerging science of geology and again
you can see the vertical sequence of
rocks a kind of rubbery layer and then
the succeeding sequence and then the
modern layer on top this image and the
ideas behind it did not seem to have
raised the hackles of the clergy I'm not
a scholar of religious history but to me
that suggests that in that era the
timescales of Genesis were generally
accepted as metaphor than rather than
literal truth it wasn't really until
paleontology began to uncover evidence
of extinct creatures and vanished
ecosystems and then when Darwin of
course suggested how organisms including
humans could have evolved through the
non-directed process of natural
selection that the church began to see
geology as a threat I want to
acknowledge that many other cultures
around the world probably did not have
the same aversion to deep time and the
idea of biological evolution that the
judeo-christian West has had but I focus
here on the European tradition because
it is in fact where modern geology and
the calibration of deep time got its
start anyway at this point in the 21st
century geology has been contending with
creationists and young Arthur's for more
than 150 years and it's easy to be
derisive about young earth thinking but
I do emphasize empathize with people who
are truly struggling to reconcile their
religious beliefs
scientific understanding cognitive
dissonance hurts I occasionally have
students who are in this position and I
offered them a variation on an argument
made by Descartes in his meditations on
the nature of reality early in an intro
geo class one begins to understand that
rocks are not nouns but verbs records of
processes this limestone signifies the
accretion of a coral reef that garnet
schist represents the growth of a
mountain belt so I asked these students
to consider which is more heretical to
accept the idea of an old and evolving
earth set in motion 4.5 billion years
ago whose internally consistent history
a remarkable Oh inspiring saga has been
worked out little by little over the
past two centuries by people from many
cultures or a deceitful Creator who has
planted false clues about the planets
past in every nook and cranny from
fossil beds to zircon crystals we may
one day analyze just to mislead us
deliberately and let students decide for
themselves but I have no patience for
the aggressive misinformation the awful
mashup of biblical literalism with
alleged science that is posted online by
the Institute for Creation Research and
turned into lucrative business ventures
at places like the Creation Museum in
Kentucky to those who actively distort
scientific facts and fog the brains of
young Earthlings not to become fused
with young earthers I would say ok then
live with the consequences of your
worldview you won't have access to
fossil fuels since the gas in your car
was found by geologists with an
understanding of the stratigraphic
record likewise modern medicine is off
limits
since it's based on testing on mice
which only makes sense if you understand
that they are our evolutionary kin
apocalypticism is a dangerous offshoot
of religiously motivated time denial in
which not only the geologic past but the
future our foreshortened if you think
there's no future then there's no need
to conserve or be concerned with climate
change in fact not using up resources is
paradoxically wasteful but again young
earth there's at least completely open
about their aversion to time more
insidious forms of time denial are woven
into the fabric of our culture
our natural as extensional dread of
aging and death has become entangled
with vanity through capitalistic
messaging in a society obsessed with
youth as a result we fear and lothar
time eNOS making us afraid of time is
big business time denial is a
multi-billion dollar industry at least
this product seems to be completely
forthright about being utterly detached
from reality
have you noticed these days we more
often refer to ourselves as consumers
rather than citizens and that doesn't
really bother anyone citizen implies
living somewhere over time in proximity
to others with attendant give and take
that that requires consumer suggests
only taking as if our sole purpose were
to devour everything in sight now in the
manner of locusts descending on a field
of grain with no thought of the
consequences for the future and we are
as insatiable as locusts for novelty the
newest smartphone the just-released
app the meme of the moment the latest
elixir of life we don't notice how
quickly all of these age become old
tired so five minutes ago because the
next ones arrived to take their place
before we've had a chance to dwell on
that allowing us to remain pleasantly
distracted in a never-ending now this
narcissistic preoccupation with our own
creations has led to a mass illusion
that we've outgrown the natural world in
this country in particular particular
there's a widely accepted notion of
virtual credo that free markets
represent an almost sacred natural state
that anything that fetters them
including protections for nature itself
which produces the raw goods for the
never satisfying economic monster is
unnatural and while we may scoff at
apocalyptic thinking the opposite view
that we can carry on forever at
increasing levels of resource
consumption is equally diluted in 2016
the novelist Amitabh gosh published this
provocative series of essays originally
written as a lecture series at the
University of Chicago in which he makes
the point that so far literary fiction
has failed to address climate change the
central issue of our time he reminds us
that literature has often anticipated
and catalyzed revolution
in human society from ending slavery to
and regulating meatpacking even but he
argues few serious novelists have yet
found a way to write compellingly about
impending changes in the natural world I
would say that in just the last year or
so several prominent writers have risen
to this challenge for example Louise
Erdrich in the future home of the Living
God and Richard powers in the overstory
still I think Ghosh articulates an
important idea that we in the West have
little appetite for stories without
individual human protagonists that that
is essential if we are to take action on
global environmental challenges the
title has two meanings
the derangement we have caused to nature
and the derangement in our belief that
we are outside the narrative of nature
and here is where science and geology in
particular can do can help by doing a
better job of telling the remarkable
stories of the natural world
Tolstoy yin in the number of characters
these come in all genres some
heartwarming some terrifying some
cryptic some stranger than fiction but
it must also be acknowledged that
science itself is culpable for subtle
strains of time denial in the hierarchy
of Sciences it's telling that the pure
that is the timeless eternal one's
physics but also chemistry our most
esteemed while biology and geology which
positively reek of time and history are
implicated by implication impure there's
no Nobel Prize in geology though there
is one in economics I respect the
accomplishments of other Sciences
geology is infected a very
interdisciplinary field that necessarily
draws on the principles and methods of
physics chemistry and biology but many
environmental problems we face are the
result of the failure in the early to
mid 20th century to anticipate how new
technologies the internal combustion
engine chemical fertilizers antibiotics
plastics would interact over time with
complex evolving natural systems the
scientists and engineers behind these
innovations could have used a bit of
geologic thinking time fulness an
unfortunate reality is that the
unintentional consequences of our
technologies will almost all
always outlive our intentional
implementation of them to think
geologically is not as much about time
itself as the power of time to
inexorably alter entangle magnify ramify
and otherwise complicate but geology -
as a discipline has been at fault for
failing to put human and Planetary
timescales in proper perspective first
for a variety of reasons geology is a
late-bloomer it's a bit embarrassing to
note that the laws of thermodynamics
were worked out in the 19th century the
structure of the atom in the early 20th
but plate tectonics the way the solid
earth works was not figured out until
1965 some of the delay was technological
earth was just too close and too big to
see clearly before that time but it was
also partly due to the myopia and lack
of imagination of the majority of
geologists in the early to mid 20th
century who are too preoccupied with
locating coal oil and mineral resources
to recognize the clear evidence that
earth is a dynamic planet that was
continuously reconfiguring itself
another ironic reason for public time
illiteracy is that in some ways
geologists have been too emphatic about
the immense antiquity of the earth and
slowness of geologic processes as a
result of our conscient constant
vigilance against young earthers I'm
sure you're all familiar with the
24-hour clock analogy for geologic time
if the 4.5 billion year history of Earth
were condensed into a 24-hour period
modern humans would emerge at just the
last fraction of a second before
midnight but I think this is really a
wrongheaded depiction in several ways
first it's alienating it suggests we
appeared out of nowhere and design
denies our deep roots in the
evolutionary past
yes we humans in present form are
relatively recent arrivals but our
ancestors have been here since the early
morning hours and it seems to absolve us
from responsibility for our actions how
could anything we've done in that last
fraction of a second matter to the earth
also as those of you who live in a
tectonic lien geologically active area
know earth is really not so sluggish it
has many temples moods and modes
sometimes too fast for us to keep up
with and there are unfortunate
asymmetries in
rates of processes evolution is slow but
extinctions can be brutally sudden
sliding into an ice age is generally
gradual but warming up is often abrupt
ground water accumulates for centuries
or millennia but can be depleted in
decades finally another reason that
geologic thinking has not made inroads
into public discourse is that the field
frankly has a PR problem for many people
it either evokes musty museums it seems
to be a dim about a dim and irrelevant
past or about rapacious resource
extraction in most of the country and
California may again be an exception
there are no rigorous engaging courses
in modern Geoscience in most high
schools so few people are aware of the
field as a distinct discipline and
that's one reason that many geologists
including me came into the field almost
by accident I do recall as a first
grader having a fascination with soot
say a new island formed off the coast of
Iceland in the 1960s in school we
watched a movie showing the spires of
steam and hot ash shooting out at the
cold North Atlantic it suggested a
secret life force inside the stony-faced
earth that terrified and thrilled me but
no one said people called geologists
study such things and ten subsequent
years of uninspired school science and
not one female mentor drummed out of me
any nascent thought of becoming a
scientist as a freshman in college I
signed up for geology almost on a whim
my expectations were low everybody
called it rocks for jocks
I found that it was a different kind of
science that required a type of whole
brain thinking I hadn't encountered
before it demanded the humanities like
close reading of the texts of the
natural world it involved the rigorous
application of physics and chemistry to
wild and unruly things like volcanoes
and oceans and above all it required a
vivid but disciplined imagination the
capacity for visualization across great
expanses of time and space and I saw its
vast explanatory power it was nothing
less than the etymology of the whole
world geology is a strange hybrid of the
pragmatic and the philosophical it's
about where to find oil and groundwater
how to protect people from natural
hazards but also about deep existential
matters where do we come from why is the
earth the way it is what factors favour
stable resilient ecosystems and
societies and it's a as much about the
future as the past an apt metaphor for
geologic thinking is that of a
palimpsest manuscript like this one in
medieval times texts texts written on
parchment a commodity that required a
lot of labour to produce we're often
scraped off and reused multiple times
but always vestiges of the earlier texts
remained similarly landscapes have their
histories written all over them scraped
by erosion and overwritten many times
once you become attuned to these earlier
scribblings it's impossible not to see
them I often feel like I don't just live
in Wisconsin but in many Wisconsin's
there are forests still recovering from
nineteenth-century clear-cutting
there are the great lakes and mighty
rivers that governed ancient trade
routes long before he pians arrived
legacies themselves of the immense eye
slopes that float down from Canada
they're the golden Cambrian sand stones
marking the shores of long vanished seas
and in the North contorted gneisses that
are the surviving roots of Proterozoic
mountains but every place on earth has
similar stories sprawling million
generation sagas of stability and
upheaval seas rolling in and out
glaciers advancing and retreating
mountains rising and being erased by
erosion reconstructing Earth's past from
the raw rock record
truly one of humanity's great
intellectual achievements but it's
underappreciated because it wasn't done
by a solitary genius but instead built
up incremental II by castes of thousands
over the last two centuries
it's truly astonishing that we've been
able to retrieve so much information in
such detail about most of Earth's
biography but the geologic time scale is
still a work in progress there's plenty
of for future generations of
geoscientists to decipher I recognized
that some people feel diminished by
geologic time that humans are made
insignificant by it and I can understand
that I think it helps to start
developing some depth of field in
thinking about time I had a math teacher
who was fond of saying there are many
sizes and shapes of infinity and while
geologic time is not infinite it is long
some past events like the Pleistocene
the Ice Age happened just the other day
others say the formation of Pangaea a
while ago and some the origin of life
for instance a long time back it's also
useful to adopt the Greek distinction
between Chronos raw time billions and
billions of years and Kairos which is
time within a narrative as one starts
knowing Earth's story and those vast
stretches of geologic time are filled
with narratives protagonists and plot
lines it's no longer alienating the
characters become familiar the themes
resonant once we open a few volumes in
the library of deep time we can begin to
recognize ourselves in the tales of
earlier Earthlings indeed I find the
idea of a seven or eight thousand year
old earth with a shallow short history
positively terrifying while the
enveloping presence of so many ancestors
with such a rich anthology anthology of
life stories to share is to me deeply
comforting so let me describe three
salient lessons from the rock record
that our ancestors have to share with us
about surviving over the long term first
worship the Sun the earliest records we
have of life fossilized algal mats
called stromatolites like these still
living in Shark Bay Australia as well as
certain geochemical traces of microbial
activity point to photosynthesis as one
of the earliest strategies for
nourishment
and although we've discovered a few
ecosystems that seem to be entirely
independent from the Sun living off
chemical injured energy from deep-sea
vents and in some cases directly off
rocks deep underground even many of
these species seem to have descended
from sun-loving ancestors love of the
Sun what might be called Helio philia is
quite natural earth and life are both
children of the Sun the earth an
incidental byproduct of the sun's
formation does generate its own internal
heat by radioactive decay these days as
a middle-aged planet at a rate of around
30 terawatts that's enough power to
power the global plate tectonic system
but this is far outstripped by the
energy coming to Earth from the Sun
about 200,000 terawatts nearly 10,000
times more than what leaks out of the
planets interior the sun's energy drives
the water cycle weather and winds and
fuels the biosphere the Sun evaporates
an oceans worth of water every 4,000
years technically fossil fuels - are a
form of solar energy products of ancient
photosynthesis but as we all know
there's an unfortunate and ironic
side-effect of burning this archived
sunshine the emissions from fossil fuel
combustion especially carbon dioxide but
also nitrous oxides and soot profoundly
changed the way the planet metabolizes
the sunlight reaching earth now and of
course these archives are ultimately and
maybe thankfully finite in fact trivial
by geologic measures the remaining
economically recoverable fossil fuels in
the world have an estimated total energy
content of around 10 to the 23rd joules
equivalent to about a month of solar
radiation reaching the earth luckily the
forecast for the next few billion years
is sunshine
a second lesson from the earth be loopy
dance endlessly around in circles that
is recycle Earth is basically a closed
system other than a fine rain of comets
and micro meteorites and the occasional
dinosaur killing asteroid earth has not
acquired any significant new mass since
it formed 4.5 billion years ago yet the
median age of continental surface rocks
is only about 500 million years the
oldest ocean crust is 170 million years
old the oceans are refreshed every few
millennia and as Hutton noted soil is
constantly washed to the sea but so far
hasn't disappeared this means that
everything on the planet is in sense an
incessantly recycled reforged and
restocked the water air soil the very
crust of the earth at vastly different
rates via evaporation precipitation
oxidation-reduction subduction
metamorphism melting crystallization
erosion and mountain building are reused
reacted and remade every process has an
inverse operation every flow a
compensatory counter flow in an
intricate system of checks and balances
it's like an elaborate contra dance
happening across many spatial and time
scales in which after many rounds
everybody ends up back where they
started in fact this tendency for
infinite repetition and reinvention is
the single most important attribute that
distinguishes Earth from its sister
planets it's not simply that earth
happened to be the right size and
distance from the Sun but that it
developed habits as a young planet that
have kept its surface environment
Clement for most of the past four
billion years life on Earth got involved
in the circular logic early on in the
biosphere commodities are by necessity
used at rates commensurate with their
abundance if an essential element is
very scarce organisms have only a few
options learn to live with extremely
limited amounts of the commodity
specialize in harvesting it from the
environment and or find ways to recycle
it for repeated use giving that given
that the alternative is extinction
organisms have come up with ingenious
strategies to make a little go a long
way the biogeochemist
Tyler Volk suggested that the frugality
of biological systems can be quantified
but what he caught by what he calls a
cycling
it's the amount of a commodity that
changes hands in an ecosystem divided by
the amount that exits that biotic system
in the given period of time essentially
the number of times that the element or
molecule is traded between organisms
before becoming locked up in sediment or
returning to the atmosphere a resource
that has reused many times the transport
between organisms for example soil
microbes plants herbivores carnivores
scavengers decomposers before leaving
the biotic system will have a higher
cycling ratio than one that is taken and
discarded after a single use the values
of natural cycling ratios vary over many
orders of magnitude depending on what
systems and resources ones considering
but cycling ratios are always inversely
correlated with availability that is the
scarce or the resource the more the
biosphere will recycle it so let's
consider two elements needed by life
forms calcium used by calcifying
organisms like these little caca little
fours to form shells and exoskeleton and
also by our own branch of the animal
kingdom for bones and nitrogen essential
for all life forms from bacteria to
Buffalo at the cellular level of these
calcium is by far the more abundant to
the Earth's crust
it represents between two and ten weight
percent of average speaking Ashraf's
at the in the near surface and has a
pretty low cycling ratio not quite two
so calcium is akin to a disposable
coffee cup used once and sent to the
landfill except that in nature even that
which is discarded by the biosphere
finds utility in the inorganic realm in
particular calcium carbonate or calcite
secreted by these organisms most of them
tiny like these tiny Kaka lists
accumulate to form limestone and in this
is Earth's ingenious long term carbon
sequestration method more about that in
a minute nitrogen which is virtually
absent from rocks is abundant in the
atmosphere but not in a form accessible
to any organisms except for a few
experts highly specialized nitrogen
fixing but microbes in the soil on the
sea Volk estimates that the global
biological cycling ratio of nitrogen is
more than a thousand that is the average
atom of nitrogen is exchanged between
organisms a thousand times before
exiting the bye
but as we know from the growing dead
zones in the oceans in the Gulf of
Mexico Chesapeake Bay the Baltic Sea and
elsewhere when organisms do have access
to abundant nitrogen they just can't
control themselves they gorge on it and
then in decomposing suck the oxygen out
of the water which in turn kills others
leading to more anoxia over geologic
time biogeochemical cycles evolved to be
exquisitely balanced elegantly
choreographed with all participants
moving in stately synchrony ro fish
alterations to them are something like
driving a tractor into the contra dance
it's sobering to note that all of the
great mass extinction events of the
geologic past have been linked with
severe disturbances to the carbon and
other biogeochemical cycles even the
dinosaur extinction event which of
course is linked with a meteorite impact
was ultimately caused by ensuing
upheavals in the chemistry of the oceans
in the atmosphere and the bedrock story
of the greatest mass extinction in
earth's history the end-permian
Cataclysm tells how a thriving global
biosphere was nearly dealt a mortal blow
by the combined effects of abrupt
volcanic ly induced greenhouse warming
ocean acidification and widespread
marine and Axia a scenario chillingly
familiar to Anthropocene listeners we
have made small steps toward learning
the biogeochemical contra dance these
days and most municipalities recycling
of containers and paper is mainstream
and that's a good thing but it obscures
an ugly truth in this country although
we're recycling at a much higher
percentage of our household waste about
35% now than we did in 1960 which was
about 3% the total amount of waste we
generate each day has grown even faster
so depressingly the yearly amount of per
capita non recycled waste has actually
increased also a few manufactured goods
attain cycling ratios of even two even
though the components in them like rare
earth elements are very scarce and
environmentally damaging to extract and
too often recycling or even repair is
not possible because gadgets like
computers cell phones coffee makers and
so many others are not designed to be
dismantled and parts can neither be
reused nor replaced we used to get much
higher cycling ratios scores in frontier
to be frugal and resourceful was a
necessity a virtue the very heart of our
national identity today consumer
spending is considered the best metric
of the nation's health and of course the
big elephant or element in the room is
carbon namely our non looping
uncompensated one-way injection of it as
co2 into the atmosphere an unjust fact
about carbon emissions is that while one
part of the world the US Canada and
Western Europe have been responsible for
a disproportionate share of the output
over the past century the whole world
suffers the consequences this is because
the mixing time in the troposphere the
lower atmosphere is that's the time it
takes for turbulent stirring by winds
and weather to homogenize the air on a
global scale is relatively short about a
year compared with the residence time of
carbon in the atmosphere which is about
a hundred years or more
if the mixing time were long compared
with the residence time then co2 would
hover close to the places where it was
released like garbage piling up when
trash haulers strike and might motivate
action to emit less but because our
individual emissions are not only
invisible but conveniently dispersed
around the world we have felt little
incentive to concur tail them we've been
living for a long time like the loose
protagonist in Oscar Wilde's picture of
dorian gray who in spite of a reckless
narcissistic lifestyle of gluttony and
drunkenness as well as cruel and immoral
behavior mysteriously remained youthful
and handsome for decades in the end his
horrible secret is revealed for years a
portrait of him he kept hidden in the
Attic had accumulated the effects of his
debauchery and when it is brought into
the light the full horror of his
contemptible lifestyle is revealed now
we're getting to that point with carbon
emissions our first priority should be
to cut emissions dramatically and
immediately but at the same time look
for ways to put our carbon away not in
the Attic but the way nature does some
pilot carbon sequestration technologies
take their cue directly from the same
quiet underappreciated geologic process
that Earth has used for years - imagine
to manage co2 exhalations from volcanoes
namely chemical weathering of calcium
and magnesium burying igneous rocks the
combined
with co2 in the form of new carbonate
minerals like Kelly the principle
component of limestone and in simplified
form the equation that sits on the upper
left there is encapsulate this it's co2
in the atmosphere reacts through water
rain with an average crustal minerals CA
SiO 3 and then in solution those are
carried to the sea where some of it's
picked up by silica based organisms like
sponges and diatoms and then the rest is
picked up by caca lists and other
calcifying organisms this is the
carbonate silicate cycle over very long
timescales
this is the thing that has kept earth
from becoming a runaway greenhouse
planet like Venus
unfortunately in nature this process
mediated by biological precipitation of
calcite is too slow to keep up with
anthropogenic co2 emissions which now
outpaced those of volcanoes by a factor
of more than 50 and in fact as the
oceans become more acidic this mechanism
is actually slowing down because it
becomes harder for marine organisms like
those tiny Kaka lifts to form shells as
the pH of seawater Falls it may be
possible however using a particularly
reactive type of rock magnesium-rich
peridotite to speed up the process of
fixing carbon and mineral form at
land-based sites the catch is that
although peridotite is very uh abundant
in the earth it makes up most of the
Earth's mantle it's quite rare at
Earth's surface but there are places
including Newfoundland Oman Cyprus and
not that far from here up in the Klamath
mountains where past tectonic upheavals
have thrust slabs of mantle rock up onto
the edges of continents it's an
appealing idea that rock from the
interior of the earth could help us mend
the damage we've done to the atmosphere
the problem of course is that
transporting carbon concentrated coverin
dioxide say from power plants to the
peridotite the rare occurrences of it or
vice versa would itself be an energy
intensive process and while there have
been some promising recent results from
experiments in Iceland using basalt
which is a much more common rock type
even the most optimistic researchers
emphasize that enhanced mineral
sequestration of co2 could never keep up
with our still rising emissions other
innovators are hoping to find scalable
ways to catch
a few co2 directly from the atmosphere
but these are too expensive to implement
as long as we can in the manner of
Dorian Gray keep spewing out carbon for
free with no personal consequences but
the good news is that we already have
the technology to capture co2 directly
from the air and simultaneously create a
versatile building material it's called
trees photosynthesis is still the best
bargain around for carbon captured one
last lesson from the geologic record to
adopt the mantra of a copy of economist
EF shoemaker small is powerful
gargantuan creatures and enormous
calamities dominate popular depictions
of the geologic past tyrannosaurus
woolly mammoths mega volcanoes and giant
asteroids make for better entertainment
than do photosynthesizing cyanobacteria
and imperceptibly slow changes in the
landscape but the fact is earth's most
dramatic topography is sculpted mainly
by raindrops and snowflakes and while
hulking monsters have come and gone
microorganisms have survived and in fact
been in charge the whole time this is
what I call my croc recei ruled by the
tiny
the modern science of gia of geology
actually began with the recognition of
the might of the minut the realization
that Earth's surface was shaped not by
biblical Cataclysm but rather by
apparently inconsequential incremental
processes integrated over space and time
this principle was also essential for
Darwin's epiphany that the subtlest
variations and the traits of organisms
have given flower to the immense
diversity of life although the
inexorable workings of natural selection
have led to some truly colossal beasts
it is no in no sense hyperbolic to say
that microbes bacteria algae protozoa
fungi viruses govern the biosphere they
are the base of aquatic food chains they
are critical to the biogeochemical
contra dance closing nutrient cycling
loops by breaking down organic matter
they populate every conceivable
environment on the planet and mediate
the chemistry of soils the oceans and
the atmosphere they even eat rapaciously
away at rocks acids produced by
microorganisms accelerate chemical
dissolution of rocks at Earth's surface
by many orders of magnitude if the
metric of success is longevity they are
by far the most successful group of
organisms they appeared within a few
million years hundred million years of
Earth's formation and reigned alone for
three billion years before macroscopic
life forms showed up when even larger
creatures and their baroque ecosystems
have repeatedly risen and fallen in
evolutionary radiations and extinctions
microbes simple versatile resourceful
have quietly persisted we've employed
them for centuries to make bread cheese
and beer but only recently come to
appreciate the micro biomes in our own
bodies where there are more guest
bacterial cells than native animal cells
most of these are benign and many are
essential to digestion and healthy skin
but of course there are also microbial
villains if anyone is skeptical that we
live in a micro cracy consider that few
modern humans worry about being eaten by
large carnivores but do fear measles
ecoli HIV MRSA c-diff and other
lilliputian adversaries as formidable
enemies or powerful allies
microorganisms teach us that tiny is not
the
equivalence of trivial although my
Crocker C is ubiquitous in the natural
world there is something deeply
counterintuitive about it perhaps
because evolution has programmed us to
be more wary of large fast-moving
carnivores than slow incremental threats
to our existence or maybe it's because
human societies too often vest power in
the rich the belligerent the
self-aggrandizing and others at the top
of the food chain my croc recei is in
essence the principle underlying
democracy but even in well-established
republics we struggle not to succumb to
skepticism about whether our
participation matters we too often
interpret the egalitarian dissemination
of power as individual helplessness
despairing that our solitary actions or
lone votes will have no effect on the
environment or the outcome of an
election we forget that the potency of
my chakra sees whether bacterial or
political arises not simply from the
sheer numbers of individuals but from
the networks of connectivity among them
certain strains of bacteria and even
some insects can coordinate their
collective behavior via quorum sensing
biochemical signaling that allows the
decentralized population to assess its
own size and respond appropriately to
its environment depending on the species
in the setting this can lead either to
healthy guts and thriving ecosystems or
to cholera epidemics and plagues of
locusts the Internet is the most obvious
anthropological illustration of the
potency and peril of a highly
interconnected mikroc recei it has
empowered millions of ordinary people by
providing access to libraries of
information and connections to virtual
communities around the globe but it has
also spawned new viral subcultures of
hate disinformation crime and
exploitation mikroc recei like democracy
does not guarantee good outcomes in both
systems small changes can become
magnified and lead either to prosperity
or pathology the key is to identify the
good bacteria and find ways to nourish
those live and active cultures so these
are just a few examples of the wise
principles and cautionary tales from the
rock record for me knowing the long
story arc of the earth and chance the
world and enriches my experience of
being alive in it now
by establishing a sense of kinship with
other humans and with all denizens of
this planet past present and future
but this poly temporal perspective is at
odds with our long cherished belief that
we humans are exceptional and with the
more recent conviction that our time is
somehow utterly disjunct and set apart
from all other eras in his contemplation
of the paradoxes of modernity French
philosopher Bruno Latour has observed we
humans have a peculiar propensity for
understanding time that passes as if it
were really abolishing the past behind
it and that we are separated from
earlier times by epistemic ruptures so
radical that nothing of the past
survives in the last decade this feeling
of estrangement from the past has become
magnified by the embrace of disruption
as an intrinsically good and necessary
thing in commerce and culture we admire
those who move fast and break things but
this view of time as a scorched-earth
kind of process is stealth and itself an
epistemic rupture with the past not to
mention a dangerous delusion that leads
to a variety of ills including an
alphabetical order
angst enemy hubris impatience narcissism
neurosis pettiness spiritual malaise and
other maladies earlier civilizations had
different and arguably more
sophisticated perceptions of time in
most pre-modern cultures the past
hovered over the present ancestors were
felt to be watching past and future
generations were understood to be
knitted into one fabric the medieval
Scandinavian worldview included the
concept of veers loosely fate or the
power of the past to shape the present
and future the earth was embodied in the
world tree each draw seal which gives
structure to all of time and space it
was maintained by the mysterious female
Norns who water it from an ancient and
continuously replenishing well while
reciting the or log the internal worlds
that hold up the eternal laws that hold
up the world in Ghanaian tradition
there's the concept of Sankofa usually
symbolized by a backward-looking bird
and associated with the proverb it is
not wrong to go back for that which you
have forgotten in other words move for
but remember the past there's the
Buddhist concept of sati usually
translated as mindfulness but actually
something closer to memory of the
present suggesting a subtler
relationship with time in these
traditions and many others the past
present and future coexist and interact
in ways much more nuanced than our
simplistic linear view of time in our
culture we tend to mistake technological
prowess for wisdom the people we call
visionaries base their conceptions of
the future on the notion that we should
do everything in our power to circumvent
that are some constraints of the natural
world that have shackled hapless
denizens of the past not appreciating
that earth is so much more powerful and
more patient than we are and will always
prevail the idea that earth time just
doesn't apply to us leads to the
delusion that we can outsmart the
complex system of biogeochemical cycles
and for example magically solve our
climate woes through stratospheric
sulfate injection and expect that there
won't be a powerful backlash of
unintended consequences as if contra
dancers reorganize themselves disrespect
for time also seduces us into thinking
that we could skip over all that
inefficient millions of years of
coevolution stuff and just terraform
ourselves another planet engineering the
climate or terraforming Mars sound easy
if you're completely unaware of the
intrinsic timescales of geological and
biological phenomena the deep
evolutionary pathways that gave rise to
the world we live in the intricately
choreographed behind-the-scenes
biogeochemical cycles the housekeeping
crew that make earth habitable such
ideas are beyond hubris revealing not
only a profound ignorance of the earth
but also of human nature what makes us
think we could successfully change the
rules that govern this or another planet
when we haven't even learned to govern
ourselves anthropologist clifford geertz
famously defined culture as the
constellation of stories that groups of
humans tell themselves about their place
and purpose in the world in Western
culture with its judeo-christian
underpinnings grafted to principles of
social democracy and capitalism the
stories we share about who we are
largely exclude
world nature is at most a passive
backdrop the scenery against which the
real stories unfold not a central
protagonist in the narrative well very
soon now that scenery is going to start
directing the play long-term thinking is
absolutely essential to grappling with
the intractable issues of our time
whether its climate change or
intergenerational poverty yet just when
the need for it is most acute our ten
attention spans are shrinking the
political and economic infrastructure we
have has few mechanisms for sustained
action over the timescales needed to
resolve our most stubborn problems
government is increasingly hamstrung by
the two-year congressional cycle and
corporate decision making is yoked to
shareholder demand for positive annual
or even quarterly returns as individuals
we hardly have time to look up from our
phones meanwhile our leaders embrace
anti-scientific magical thinking that
makes medieval worldly views like veer
to seem positively enlightened and
increasingly the only institutions that
can act on intergenerational timescales
are authoritarian governments or
foundations underwritten by the super
wealthy while the actions of many of
these organizations are laudable they
are also fundamentally undemocratic we
need to read to market read democratize
the future when we peer into the
geologic future a paradox emerges to
some extent we can see what lies in the
far distance more clearly than what is
in the foreground the Sun as a g-type
star is about halfway through its
lifespan and in five billion years or so
we'll enter its red giant phase engulfed
in the earth and the inner planets three
billion years before that however the
sun's increasing luminosity will lead to
an extreme greenhouse effects from the
vaporization of Earth's oceans once the
planet's water has been lost to space
the carbonate silicate weathering system
that has acted to sequester volcanic co2
over geologic time will shut down
creating an even more intense greenhouse
state that would likely make surface
conditions intolerable for all life
about two billion years from now for at
least the next billion years or so plate
tectonics will continue to shuttle
continents to new positions on the globe
the Atlantic Ocean will begin to close
and in about 250 million years the
we'll be reunited with Europe and Asia
in a new super continent that has
already been named Pangaea Ultima
meanwhile rivers will have erased the
Himalaya Alps and Rockies in about
80,000 years the earth will reach the
point in its orbital cycles where
another Ice Age could happen but this
will depend on greenhouse gas
concentrations ocean circulation the
state of the biosphere and many other
variables the next thousand years the
same time the amount of same amount of
time that separates us from the Viking
Age are even harder to bring into focus
if human emissions of carbon have not
sharply been curbed and powerful
positive feedbacks in the climate system
are activated the earth could experience
a replay of the paleocene-eocene thermal
maximum 55 million years ago
temperatures would spike by 8 to 10
degrees marine and land-based ecosystems
would be stressed to the point of
collapse sea level would rise tens of
feet inundating most of the world's most
populous cities altered weather patterns
more ferocious storms longer and deeper
droughts would stress world food
production increasing proportions of
government budgets that would have to be
channeled into crisis management the
balance of geopolitical power would
shift depending on how nations fare in
the new climate regime but none of this
is preordained we have the power to
write a different saga for the coming
millennium rather than lapse into
existential despair that we won't be
here in a billion years
let us reclaim at least the next few
centuries it is empowering or at least
therapeutic in these dark times to
imagine what a time literate society
might look like in his last public
interview Kurt Vonnegut said I'll tell
you one thing no cabinet has ever had is
a secretary of the future and there are
no plans at all for my grandchildren and
my great-grandchildren let us adopt
Vonnegut's suggestion as our first
proposal a representative for the yet to
be born to serve among the top advisors
to the president the Department of the
future would set in motion a realignment
of priorities in all aspects of society
and now we should cue some triumphant
music I think
the secretary will declare some new
national holidays Aldo Leopold Rachel
Carla Carson or Chief Seattle days to
honor great long-term thinkers
photosynthesis and carbonate rock week a
time to celebrate the mighty legions of
Kaka Litha fors and others who have kept
the planet from becoming a runaway
greenhouse resource conservation would
again become a core value and patriotic
virtue tax incentives and subsidies
would be rebalanced toward rewarding
long-term stewardship over short-term
exploitation putting a price on carbon
will help us get a grip on our fossil
fuel addiction sober up and let us
prepare for the natural disasters that
will happen without our assistance like
the hundreds of large earthquakes that
will happen around the globe in the next
century rather than expending resources
on self-created climate catastrophes
poverty and class-based disparity of
opportunity would be recognized as
problems with deep historical roots that
cannot be solved without sustained
commitment over commensurate timescales
into the future public school teachers
and others whose work represents an
investment in the future would be paid
well and held in high esteem geology
would be fully integrated into science
curricula
perhaps serving as a capstone course in
which students would apply physics
chemistry and biology to the immensely
complex earth system was a solid
understanding of how the planet works
students would go on to become educated
voters who would hold public officials
accountable for wise governance of water
land and air legislators governors and
mayor's who embrace the seven generation
principle would point proudly to what
they are doing and be reelected by
grateful constituents more generally
schools would help develop children's
knowledge of an appetite for history and
Natural History instilling in them a
deep instinct for their place in time
and a keen curiosity to understand more
the dramatic narratives of the geologic
past are perfectly suited to the human
appetite for storytelling like many who
experienced childhood or parenthood in
the last 50 years I love Maurice
Sendak's where the wild things are it's
a book about the power of imagination to
take us to other worlds transcend time
and save us from our worst selves I
think of Max's voyage whenever I teach
history of Earth and life a course in
which we cover Earth's four and a half
billion year history in a 10-week term
at an average clip of about 450 million
years a week
I always feel that I've been on a long
journey with my students we've witnessed
alien Earth's explored alternate
ecosystems teeming with strange wild
things through bountiful times and bad
ones
finally we approach the present and see
the modern world emerging from the mists
just as Max's room gradually sheds its
finds and becomes recognizable again I
believe perhaps naively but if more
people could experience this journey and
see themselves as earthlings with a
common past and shared destiny it might
spring us out of our polarized and
entrenched ways of thinking about the
world as a geologist I've worked with
people from all over the world from very
different cultures and generations older
and younger than mine the strong human
connections I've developed with them
through our shared study of earth make
me optimistic that a geocentric timeful
worldview might help us overcome the
animosities and barriers that divide us
and get down to work on things that
really matter
collective awareness of Earth's story
might save us from environmental hubris
understanding how historical
happenstance is written into each of our
personal lives might cause us to treat
each other with more empathy and a time
'fl habit of mine might even make us
less neurotic about the fact of our own
mortality by shifting our focus from the
finite lengths of our lives to the rich
anthology of experiences that a lifetime
represents while other senses may be
dulled with age the sense of time which
can only be developed by experiencing it
is heightened growing old requires one
to shed the illusion that there's only
one version of the world as Darwin wrote
on the last page of Origin of Species in
a sentence I will warn you with many
Commons commas and a semicolon
also there is grandeur in this view of
life with its several powers having been
originally breathed into a few forms or
into one and that whilst this planet has
gone on cycling according to the fixed
law of gravity from so simple a
beginning endless forms most beautiful
and most wonderful have been and are
being evolved that grandeur has always
included us we've simply tormented
ourselves with the idea that
outside the garden as a technological
society we have an almost art autistic
relationship with the earth we are rigid
in our habits savants when it comes to
certain narrow obsessions
but dysfunctional in many other regards
because we wrongly view ourselves is
alone in the cosmos believing that
nature is something outside us a mute
and immutable thing external to us we
are unable to empathize or communicate
with us with it but the earth is
whispering in our ears all the time in
every stone it offers an eternal truth
or a good rule of thumb in every leaf a
prototype power station in every
ecosystem a model of good urban planning
in every watershed an exemplar of a
healthy economy we need to view
ourselves not as consumers or members of
political tribes but citizens of Earth
the still evolving tangle of old
recycled sun-powered and profoundly
interdependent dancing parts there's a
teaching attributed to the 18th century
Polish Hasidic rabbi simcha boon him
that for me a very lapsed and be deeply
agnostic Scandinavian Lutheran carries
great wisdom one should carry two slips
of paper one in your left pocket reading
I am ashes and dust the other in the
right reading the world was made for me
both are true
somewhere between the poles of
existential despair and narcissistic
self absorption lies the path that will
take us back to the center of the cosmos
but our Holocene snow day is ending now
and no one is going to be waiting us
waiting for us with a warm supper it's
time to grow up and with a clear-eyed
view of both past and future resolved to
become better ancestors and start making
up for so much lost time
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much well you can all kind
of get a sense of how this lines up with
the long now way of thinking I think so
perfectly and I think the thing that
struck me more than any other thing was
how closely tied massive lengths of time
in the geologic sense were tied to that
you kind of every chapter tied to much
everyday kind of human interactions I
think that the one that struck me the
most is the idea that that Darwin of the
few books he had with him on the Beagle
was right I wonder if you talked a
little bit more about that which I
thought it's interesting that he was so
influenced by geology yes I guess I
didn't mention Lyell in the talk but he
is considered one of these patriarchs
along with Hutton of geology and really
wrote the first treatise modern treatise
on geology was called principles of
geology was three volumes and the first
volume had been published by the time
that Darwin went on the voyage of the
Beagle and he only had I don't know a
small box of books with him he studied
it in great detail and it tremendously
influenced him consciously and
subconsciously about the power of small
incremental changes to accrue over time
and accomplish large transformation so
that in itself kind of a heretical book
in the sense of the Christian sense of
time right but Oh Lyle was a really very
astute rhetorician he was a lawyer by
training and the book is written in this
kind of florid way he made a fairly
bright line between the evolution of the
physical world and humans he lighted the
possibility that maybe humans had just
emerged from physical processes so it
wasn't really until paleontology matured
a little bit more in the 1840s and 50s
and then Darwin of course publishing
origin of species that geology and the
church began to be at loggerheads with
each other and this the idea of roxas
verbs that I mean really what they are
kind of storytellers that if you
kind of need to find the right key to
unlock them and we were talking earlier
about an event that happens near where
you study a mere 1 point 8 5 billion
years ago on a very single day but I
wonder if you could elaborate a little
bit right yeah so Muskaan saying where I
live is not perhaps perceived by many
people as a mecca for geologic
expeditions but we have a lot of really
interesting old rocks and one of the
most remarkable discoveries in the last
10 or so years has been the ejecta layer
from the impact at Sudbury Ontario which
has been known as an impact crater it's
actually the second largest impact
crater on earth that's still preserved
but no one had thought to look for the
ejecta until about ten or fifteen years
ago when a high school teacher from
Thunder Bay who was fascinated with the
KT boundary story the dinosaur
extinction story said hey the rocks in
our backyard five hundred million five
hundred miles from Sudbury are just the
right age we should start looking for
the ejecta layer and once we narrowed
down the horizon that people should
start look and do you think did find it
shocked quartz crazy looking rocks
thrown up by a tsunami or something that
was caused by the impact and it's one
day one point eight five billion years
ago that we can trace almost all around
the shores of Lake Superior now Extron
it's such an amazing story and that your
book is kind of replete with these
stories of each each little each site
that people visit kind of has some
version of these stories whether it's a
coring of the earth in a site or a place
where where the earth is exposed and the
you were studying in Svalbard and what
what were those rocks telling you so
there are records of the northernmost
extension of the the Appalachian coal at
night chain that runs from you know
southern us up into the Maritime
Provinces in Canada and then Greenland
and Norway and then up into the Arctic
region so just trying to reconstruct
exactly where the plates that built
Pangaea were at that time and that Liz
bowler asks as a geologist thinking
about time fulness how do you think
about spaciousness or space fullness
hmm well I I guess I am I think
geologists especially in the pre-digital
age it had to learn to really create
mental Maps when we were working for
example in Svalbard we did not actually
have very good maps they were we mainly
mapped on air photos that had been taken
in the 1950s and often the glaciers were
at a very different place so you learn
early on as a geologist to to kind of
create mental maps of wherever you are
so I would say I think I've spacefill
and I think our place full because you
know everything you can't bring the
rocks to you you have to go out to the
rocks and so you you have the sense of
geography in space and time they're
tangled up with each other and it it
sounds like you have a more nuanced and
I think appreciative view of what it
might take to regio engineer ourselves
out of the the situation that we have
clearly kind of Geoengineer haplessly
into but you also mentioned some of
these naturally occurring elements or
minerals that could be helpful and I
wasn't exactly sure how those connect
right now I know you've had David Keith
here I'm a big skeptic and I think it's
it's a dangerously easy idea to do the
stratospheric self 80 injection into the
you know the stratosphere without fully
understanding what we're in for and we
don't have any international governance
mechanism for that but I do think that
perhaps some geo mimicry of Earth's long
term carbon sequestration project which
is limestone might be a good idea is it
is not likely to have ripple effects
it's just that we don't have a way of
bringing the co2 and the rocks that are
gonna react to do that together easily
yet so would that be used in scrubbers
or it's a you could be might and use it
may be a source or yeah I mean so first
of all you would need clean coal or
you'd need some way of sequestering
concentrated co2 and then delivering
that to places that have either
peridotite which is pretty rare
I was talking about or basalt which is
not all that rare but still usually
you've not built a power plant because
of the bedrock underneath it right so I
am NOT holding my breaths that this is
going to be the solution but there are
some promising experiments as I said in
Iceland where it's the whole place is
basalt right and and they also have
higher temperatures because of the
volcanic activity there and the kinetics
of the reactions at those temperatures
was pretty fast and they they were able
to sequester a fair amount of carbon in
a short period of time but again this is
we the geography is the problem getting
concentrated co2 to the rocks that will
react so it's and so it I mean and just
the mechanism of that reaction is that
by exposing those rocks so would be some
kind of mining operation that would or
injecting into well yeah this DEP that's
I think what most people are thinking
not mining the rocks but perforating
them and then bringing the co2 there
yeah Kevin Kelly asks that some force
some forecasts climate change happening
a significant degree in 20 years others
claim it will take centuries can
geological change happen in decades is
this an error of timescales well that's
a good question because our resolution
especially as we look farther and
farther back in the geologic record
becomes
fuzzier but we can look at ice core
records where at least for tens of
thousands of years we have near annual
resolution gets less as the ice gets
very compressed and diffusion between
layers happens a little bit but there we
can see annual to decade oh and
certainly century timescales and
sometimes change is very abrupt so when
we talk about some of the great mass
extinction events then then the
denominator this much extinction in so
many years gets harder to to discern
because our dating techniques don't have
that kind of precision but for more
recent and arguably more relevant
climate change we can say yeah sometimes
things happen pretty fast often in
response to changes in ocean circulation
that can happen on
human-like time skills and I'm another
question from the audience are
Petroleum's being created now or is this
only a case of something that could have
happened in a specific era like that I
think you mentioned I don't know if you
in tonight's talk I don't think you
mentioned the Ox great oxidization event
what kind of all of our iron was created
in one but we mined for petroleum in one
in one chronologic layer is sort of yeah
so petroleum is being created very
slowly by micro organisms raining to the
sea floor and the becoming buried and
then under and undergoing partial
decomposition but not in a way that
would allow us to tap into the oil and
gas that's being created now most of the
great oilfield throughout the world
happen to be Cretaceous age probably the
majority simply because that was a time
of very high sea level and most
petroleum is accumulating in the shallow
continental shelf areas and when you
have higher sea level you have bigger
continental shelves and it was very the
time of very high marine productivity as
well but yeah fossil fuels are still
accumulating slowly just out of much
slower rain don't happen to be burning
yes and there was a topic that came up
in your book as well that I was really
interested in it was this a game called
cooperating with the future wondering if
you could talk a little bit about that
yeah no I have to think exact I don't
remember the organization it was an
academic paper I know if I wrote it down
here yes where people were allowed in
different scenarios to make decisions
about how to to use or allocate a
resource that could be depleted and they
found not surprisingly that if there
were really kind of no incentives for
cooperation the tragedy of the Commons
would happen over and over again in
which one bad player would take his or
her more than his or her share and
everybody lost in the end but they
experimented with different sort of
cooperative strategies
and they found that in groups if people
could kind of collectively decide on
what was a reasonable take for each
player in a given period of time that
was a way of kind of restraining each of
the players and I don't remember exactly
the details frankly but I think some of
these this game theory and experiment
with building in checks and balances
that that mimic those in nature where
it's just not possible for any one
organism or one species to take it all
is is the way to go that everyone
benefits from some mutual restraint it
comes back to another question that can
broad had here that about world
governance and I think you mentioned
this in geoengineering you kind of need
it in this economic model as well you've
met you you mention it and you're kind
of I think you called it a chronic topia
which you explained here at the end of
your talk a world in which is so immured
with time that that we take it so
seriously that all of these things kind
of work out in this sets is Giusti any
any moves towards our world government
well I'm a geologist III do I feel in my
bones and I go to work every day because
I do think education is part of it that
they're just having a better sense of
the stories of the natural world will
reach people it's part of the solution
it's not the whole solution we need
economic and technological and
governmental mechanisms as well but
education is part of it and that's what
I do
so I remain optimistic we're not gonna
put you leave you on the hook for
building the next row of government
and chemically actually to follow on
question two to the one about our
recreating Petroleum's now but that and
I've heard this theory as well from from
Danny Hillis one of our other founders
that the petroleum may not be from so
much from dead plants but from a geo
genic geochemical process do you find
there's any I don't think they're
mutually exclusive I guess I would say
and I'm not I'm not in the petroleum
industry but we can look at some of the
organic compounds and we can see a
continuum if you if you bake photo
plankton at a certain temperature period
of time you see biochemical markers that
certainly are consistent with their
origins from biogenic sources but there
are many things we don't understand
about the way the earth works yet then I
would not deny the possibility that in
some cases we were getting these organic
compounds generated in other ways or an
interplay between the two oh yeah
exactly and I think back to your
thoughts on you know how we create and
mimic the systems of these kind of
recycling systems that the earth has one
of the questions here just let me just
say Jim Law Blog happy birthday yes
indeed because that's really his view of
the earth it's just amazing
amalgam we call it biogeochemistry not
Gaia but that's really what we're
talking about right is that you know
basically that maybe we we really under
appreciate our waste and that our
problem is not so much that we're
creating waste but we are not we haven't
created the right cycles the way that
nature has and does that kind of fit
those yeah yeah and and just consuming
way too much in them anyway you know
accelerating some of the processes that
do happen in nature by my orders of
magnitude it's just impossible to find
ways to have compensate encounter flows
as we do in nature it's just the
magnitude of our activities is too large
and I think Angus McGrath talks a little
bit about the idea of you know we we
seem to be able to grasp the fact that
our
our lives and that of our children and
grandchildren can be 200 plus years yet
we seem to only be rewarding these
vastly shorter time scales even though
we we do we do have value in that future
in some way and I think do you do you
have some sense of of what's what's
holding us back from being able to act
in this market we blame our evolutionary
roots that we aren't programmed
hardwired to be able to think past our
next meal but I you know come on we've
achieved so many other things why can't
we find the self restraint and political
will to act on on what we say our values
are I don't know well I think you
touched on it a little bit what the idea
is behind a Seminole Schaeffler in the
book where this idea that if we if if we
didn't think that there was a future to
hand the world off to we would actually
act radically different than we did it
would be a very hopeless time so we sort
of act that way but we still have this
kind of strange hope that the future
will either fix it or deal with it I can
you explain a little bit more about
Schaeffler so I guess yeah so his he's a
philosopher I think it's more I'm not
sure but he provocatively has pointed
out that psychologically we count on
future generations coming after us it
would be a terrifying thing to Kant to
think that we are the last and I think
the there was a movie children of God
that was based on PD James novel that's
sort of the premise and so we owe future
generations our sanity arguably and so
we probably owe them something in return
our sanity is due to them so we should
do the best we can to take care of them
because they are keeping us from going
insane
yeah that's an interesting place a
different way of being a good ancestor
yes and Jessie Kate
Singler asks on a on a universal G like
geologic time scale how might we think
about or define sustainability of
humanity as we become a multiplanetary
species sounds like you're you're you're
dubious of our multiplanetary in this I
am so I don't know how to answer the
question that quite in the context you I
I do think it is naive of us to imagine
that in a few generations first of all
that we could cooperate enough together
to to actually transform saint-mars
which seems the best prospect into
anything like a hospitable place without
so much high-tech intervention that it's
not really going to be relevant to the
most of the rest of the population of
Earth because of my understanding of the
way the Earth's system has evolved earth
has not been the same through all of its
history I think that's one thing that
has changed in my time as a geologist
thirty years or so we see that earth
story is kind of a bildungsroman it's a
developmental story and Earth has had
many different modes certainly the
biggest biogeochemical change was the
great oxygenation event that happened
about 1.85 billion years ago where we
went from an atmosphere that was
probably mostly co2 and water vapor to
one that at least at some free oxygen
not 21% like we do now but some which
changed all the biogeochemical rules and
then there was a second jump only about
600 million years ago to something like
near modern values so there are really
different chapters in Earth's story and
maybe that could be sped up a little bit
on another planet but I mean the
timescales here are are large and we
don't even know all the players involved
we have only a tiny fraction of the
microbes in the world classified and
understood in terms of their metabolisms
and what they're doing for us behind the
scenes so I just find it
very naive to think that we're going to
be able to go to another planet and
manage biogeochemistry on that scale
yeah do you think going there and yeah I
agree yeah I think though that there's
even value and going and failing that
the the showing of the difficulty in a
way you know if you know if a few humans
get there and they you know can barely
survive and and pretty much have to
vacate or can only survive from massive
influx of energy from earth and supplies
I would argue I can do that with
modeling well I can but I don't think it
changes the global perception right like
so it's it's I think you know one of the
things we're talking about is changing
global perception and I think you know
there's there's all kinds of things that
happen from exploration that are that
are beneficial I think to humanity that
are intangible and other way is that
going like see the price tag and see
whether we could put that same amount of
money toward other the newer offers for
there but there was the biosphere -
people may remember this from the early
1990s this closed ecosystem or allegedly
closed in the Arizona desert where maybe
it was the scale it was too small but
they even on that scale with everything
quantified and inventoried very well
they were not able to control the oxygen
levels and finally had to open the place
up because the people were getting
really cranky and irritable with each
other because they were getting only 14%
oxygen and the problem was that there
was too rich soil in the the
agricultural sector of the vise here -
and even though people have tried to
calculate exactly how much co2 that's
that soil would be respiring they were
way off and you know within a couple of
I think it was closed for about eight
months but they had to open it up
because people were just unable to
function they had altitude sickness
essentially the whole time right yeah
yes I'm an experiencer I think those
experiments are helpful for Humanity
because I think there are you a model a
model is is a model but having watching
humans suffer is a little bit
and probably will capture imaginations a
little bit better and as a last question
Kevin Kelley Kevin Kelley really you've
put a lot of questions in here thank you
what is the current geological heresy
that you suspect may be true so geologic
heresy something that some theory of
jail of geologic is that you that might
be fringe now that you think that you
think has legs hmm I might need to think
about that one for a while um maybe the
deep hot biosphere the idea that there
is no more microbial life living at
depth and we think that might be um you
know again I'm open to that idea in my
own field people are recognizing that
there may actually be another mode that
earth recycles crust other than
subduction this is this is kind of
controversial on say that ago a
different way that Earth's crust is
recycled besides could subduction which
has been the kind of paradigm since 1965
with the plate tectonic revolution
there's some evidence beneath the
Himalaya but there is something people
are calling drip tectonics which is not
really a very nice name but where you
have a big thick pile of continental
crust the pressure can cause the bottom
of that to become very dense metamorphic
rock that can just pull fall into the
mantle and I remember people proposing
this maybe 15 or 20 years ago and now we
have better geophysical methods for
seeing what's going on in the mantle and
it's looking like maybe that's a real
thing so I don't know if other people
care about that but that you know
I think it's interesting it was a
harebrained idea of people head and now
people coming back to it cool and you
have other things in your future other
books other projects maybe yeah I do
have a day job and so it's it's it's
hard for me to find time but I realized
that again I think there are many people
many Earthlings who who really do have
an appetite for for understanding and
haven't had the chance to take college
classes in geology so if there's an
audience I might try my hand at another
book well your writing
I think is some of the most evocative
and I think a human scaled writing to
geology since James McPhee that I that I
read on it's been amazing to find such a
patriot of long term thinking in reading
your book and now meeting you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]